let's go next to
let's go to rob from richmond rob you
are next
david can you hear me yes i can rob
hey so i think global warming the whole
conversation around it needs to be
changed a little bit i think it needs to
be more structured so
you know i
i think republicans and democrats can
get on the side of protecting
wildlife
environments
why don't we say like building kelp
forest
near the oceans brings habitats
but it also
helps drag co2 down
and it would do two things at once but i
think if you go to the minute it can get
republicans on board with it
i don't know i mean do republicans care
about dry i mean it's just not clear
that they um
i don't know that that would get them to
care presenting it in the terms you're
saying i mean it would be great if you
were right i just i've seen no evidence
that if we framed it the way you're
saying all of a sudden they care
i think i thought there was data that
they care about animal habitats and
especially moderates do
moderates probably do there's a lot of
right wingers who straight up say when i
hear about some seal or a shrew that's
endangered i don't care in fact i think
there's clips of candace oh and straight
up saying it like i don't care about
some salamander at all period and so i'm
not sure i think you're right that the
moderates would be more amenable to that
type of argument but i think they
already care more so that's those aren't
really the type of people we need to
convince
all right do you have a favorite album
by um soda esterio
no no not really i mean did you see my
exchange with the 311 bassist on twitter
is that why you're asking no no no oh no
no no that was that was bombed by stereo
sorry no i i now i'm confused no i don't
i don't have a particularly a particular
favorite album
favorite song
uh
no not even i'm not super familiar with
their music i just i have them in an
argentinian
uh playlist that a friend made and i
don't even know the names of the songs
because i just hear them
all right david thank you all right
thank you rob very much appreciate that
uh i really got called out there yeah
i'm not not well versed on the song
names all right let's take a quick break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we are going right back to the phones in
a moment